Okay, Steve. So, as in the past, would I introduce yourself?
My name is Steve Lawson. We're in a conference room in Valley Library on 11th of November 2011.
So, in our last session, we talked quite a bit about the Mayo Clinic controversy,
and I don't know we need to go over the details of that again, but I'm interested in knowing a little bit more about the response from within the Institute,
especially if there was ever a plan or an idea about developing a research program specifically in response to what the Mayo Clinic said.
I don't think that there was a plan to develop a research project in response to the Mayo Clinic studies.
I think that Pauline and Cameron and anyone else who was sympathetic to their position realized that the studies purportedly done to replicate Cameron's work were very flawed.
And as I mentioned last time, Cameron and Pauline were angry that the New England Journal of Medicine, for instance, did not publish critical letters in a timely fashion.
And typically medical journals will publish critical letters while the original clinical trial or study reported in that journal is still fresh in people's minds.
And I think Pauline actually invoked his lawyer to contact Arnold Rellman of the New England Journal of Medicine to find out what had happened to the letters that had been submitted.
Because the etiquette is that when you submit a publication or a letter to a journal for publication in that journal, you can't submit it elsewhere.
So this kind of stymied the ability of Cameron and Pauline to air their grievances about the Mayo Clinic studies in print in a journal because they had already submitted really cogent responses and Rellman seemed to be sitting on these for quite a long time.
I think finally they published something but it was nearly a year after the original study had been published and letters are read but they certainly don't attract the kind of media interest that the original study attracted.
So I think Cameron and Pauline felt that they needed to continue on showing that vitamin C had value because they were both convinced by this time that vitamin C had value for many cancer patients.
And Pauline was also becoming a little after the second Mayo Clinic trial. He had heard from Abram Hauffer, the Canadian psychiatrist who had stimulated his interest in B vitamins and schizophrenia back in the early 1960s or mid 1960s that Hauffer had been treating cancer patients with high dose vitamin C given orally as well as an expanded treatment regimen that included B vitamins.
Fatty acids, zinc and some other micronutrients and these cancer patients seem to be doing quite well.
So Pauline encouraged Hauffer to collect that data with the intent of analyzing it and then publishing it and they did that. They published two papers in the Journal of Worth and Molecular Medicine on Hauffer's observation.
So I think that this was not a response to the Mayo Clinic trials per se, but a continuation of Pauline's deep interest in vitamin C and cancer.
And Hauffer is an MD-PhD psychiatrist by training in profession and you might wonder why he was treating cancer patients.
Well, it turns out that many cancer patients, especially when given a diagnosis of prognosis of terminal cancer, developed psychological problems, depression, anxiety, and they were being referred to Hauffer by oncologists in Vancouver and Victoria in British Columbia to treat these mental manifestations that accompanied the bad news about the cancer diagnosis.
So Hauffer began treating these people for mental health issues and kind of serendipitously observed that they were living much longer in many cases than they were expected to live by their oncologists and he brought that observation to Pauline who encouraged him then to collect the data.
So Cameron and Pauline continued to be very interested in vitamin C and cancer. Cameron, I think, was a bit discouraged by the political implications of this whole embryo at the Mayo Clinic and I think he became very frustrated and discouraged.
And his attention was also turned elsewhere. He was very interested in fatty acids and cancer and had set up a project at the Institute to study the effect of oral fats in animals in a tumor model.
And he was also becoming more and more interested in AIDS and the potential value of high dose vitamin C in treating AIDS patients.
As you know, he and Pauline worked on a book together that absorbed quite a lot of Cameron's time and attention in those last years, which was never published.
Can you talk a little more about the fatty acids, blinded research?
Cameron, I believe, had known or knew of David Horbin's work in England. And Horbin had written a book on Omega-3 fatty acids. He was a researcher and I believe he was also a clinician who was very interested in the health sort of the orthomolecular approach to health using fatty acids.
And other micronutrients, but he was particularly interested in fatty acids and brain function. And Horbin, when I saw him at some point in the 1980s or early 1990s, had reported on a clinical trial, preliminary clinical trial done in England with, I believe, schizophrenia, who were given fatty acids supplementation and MRIs or computer tomography had been done of their brains.
And they found that the ventricular spaces shrunk as a result of ingestion of these fatty acids over a period of time, which also correlated with some symptomatic improvement.
So Horbin and Cameron, I think, too, were becoming very interested in the psychiatric application of fatty acids. And then, from epidemiological studies and rodent studies, it's been known for a long time that Omega-6 fatty acids, polyunsaturated fatty acids, may augment tumor development in some rodent models.
And there may be a protective effect by Omega-3 fats. So I think Cameron was interested in teasing apart those effects of different types of fatty acids in a mouse model.
And that's an experiment that was set up at the Institute.
In 1986, how to live longer and feel better is published? Is this something that the L.P.I. staff was part of it all over this entirely uphauling project unto himself?
Excuse me, Dorothy Monroe, of course, helped him with that because she was his secretary and she worked a lot on that book.
And I think he had helped perhaps from Fred Stitt, maybe some other people at the Institute, but it wasn't an institute-wide effort. It was done by Linus Pauling.
I think Stella Kerman probably helped him in getting references and things of that nature too, but as far as I know, Pauling himself produced the draft.
And I believe he shared that probably with some people including Fred Stitt for proofreading and suggestions and so forth.
But I think it was largely his project. And he directed that the royalties from that book come to the Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine because he undertook the book as an employee of the Linus Pauling.
It wasn't something he was doing on his own for financial gain. He really wanted that money to come to the Institute to support research.
What sort of reaction did you know in response to the book of people that were getting a hold of the Institute?
Well, there seemed to be a lot of interest in the book. The original Hardcover was published by W.H. Freeman. That wasn't around long.
Then there was a paperback also published by Freeman that was a what you call a trade paperback. It was larger than a regular pocketbook paperback.
And that seemed to sell very well in addition. And then shortly after the Freeman editions, the mass market paperback rights were auctioned and Avon was the successful bidder.
And it went, I think it was the best seller for Avon as well and went through many, many, many printings.
So people really responded to the book. I mean, I think it was in the New York Times bestseller list for a while. I'm not sure what the rank was or for how long. But it sold very, very well.
And I don't think that the main impact was financial revenue for the Institute to carry out research but more of an awareness of Pauline's ideas and orthomolecular medicine and the fact that a lot of this research was going on in California at the Linus Pauline Institute.
So it definitely directed attention to the Institute. But of course this was before the internet. So people reading the book and wanting to learn more about the possible impact of vitamin C and other vitamins and nutritionally essential minerals and so forth on cognitive function or health, prevention and treatment of cardiovascular disease and cancer and so forth would typically call or write to the Institute.
And that of course resulted in a huge enterprise because we didn't have very many staff to deal with all these letters that would come in.
And you and Cameron, who had been non-resident fellow in the Institute, I think moved to California to take up position as medical director maybe around 1984, 1985, somewhere in that mid-1980 period.
And as I said earlier, a lot of his effort was directed at responding to these letters and phone calls from people with medical problems who wanted to know about the putative therapeutic value of micronutrients, especially vitamin C.
And Fred Stitt also helped in that area quite a lot. Fred had joined the Institute as a volunteer in the early 1980s. He had known Pauline at Caltech and was actually thanked in Pauline's book on the chemical bond, Nature of the Chemical Bond.
So he and Pauline had a long relationship. Fred was retired and had an office at the Institute and Fred became the newsletter editor and also helped develop some standardized information packets that the Institute could send out to people who had, because at that point the volume of mail and requests was so large that oftentimes these things couldn't be handled on a personal basis because it was just overwhelming.
Some of the questions were very peculiar or idiosyncratic and required a little bit of work to answer a little research to find out what the appropriate response would be.
Some other questions were a little more generic and these information packets were designed and made to answer those more generic questions.
And Fred was heavily involved in that putting together these different generic packets that could go out to people.
So he vetted that mail for the most part. Fred and you and Cameron and Dorothy Monroe, I think Carol Bestelier had been doing this at Sandhill Road Facility.
And I don't think that she was still part of the Institute in the 1980s when we moved to the Page Mill Road Facility, but she had been doing a lot of that in Sandhill Road.
Actually, she identified quite a few issues. I think that we're very important for people to think about, especially with respect to liability, trying not to provide medical advice, but being compassionate and being helpful to people, but also not trying to tell them what to do medically because, of course, we couldn't do anything like that.
And Carol struggled with a lot of those issues and sort of laid the groundwork for a successful strategy for answering these kinds of questions.
It's interesting that Cameron was so closely involved considering his pretty heavy research to do.
Yeah. Well, I think he enjoyed it. He definitely was interested in research, but he really was a patient-oriented doctor.
And he would have been a terrific doctor to have for personal care because he was very compassionate. He was a good listener.
And he was not at all afflicted by the kind of arrogant or rushed attitude that you find in many contemporary physicians, just because the insurance reimbursement for physicians can dictate how medical practice is actually done in this country.
Doctors aren't allowed to spend much time with patients. Cameron was not like that at all. He was much more old school and really like to listen to people and their problems and then think about what the appropriate treatment or response would be.
So I think that responding to the public who brought these health questions or concerns to the institute, I think he enjoyed that.
So in 1987, we mentioned this a little bit already, but the vitamin C and AIDS research starts to take a little bit more if you can describe what that research was.
Yeah. To the best of my recollection, Rexie Jarawola had come to the institute from Johns Hopkins.
And I believe he knew John Levin at Johns Hopkins as well. John Levin had joined the institute to direct our molecular carcinogenesis program.
Which, again, really didn't have anything to do with orthomolecular medicine. It was more looking at, as I said, molecular carcinogenesis, how genes and certain proteins can be involved in the development of the cancer phenotype.
He was particularly interested in a mutant beta actin which seemed to be a reliable marker for many types of human cancer and used protein profiling extensively to do quantitative and qualitative studies of these gene products that seemed to correlate with cancer.
So Rexie was a virologist and he set up the laboratory for viral carcinogenesis because his initial interest was in set up a gallo viral carcinogenesis and carcinogenesis due to herpes virus type 2 infection because it was known at the time that infection with HSV2 increased the risk for certain types of gynecologic cancers in women.
I'm not sure that it's related to any increased cancer risk for men but there was an increased cancer risk for women.
And I worked with him to some degree in that program. We were looking at small fragments of herpes virus type 2 DNA that were sufficient to cause transformation of rat cells.
So we would grow rat 2 cells which are quasi-normal cells in culture and then transfect them with these small viral fragments from herpes virus type 2 and look to see if there were any observable changes in these rat cells.
And we found the PST 2 or 3 C segment was sufficient to cause the rat 2 cells to become overt tumor forming cells when injected into animals.
We also did a lot of protein profiling. I had expertise in protein profiling at that time and rat seed really didn't so that was what I brought to his project.
And together we also worked on a program that was supported by a philanthropist from Long Island New York on Phytic acid which is found in seeds.
It's an antioxidant that protects seeds from oxidation because seeds need to store their genetic program very carefully and be free from oxidative damage while they're waiting to germinate until the conditions are right for germination.
Phytic acid plays a very important role in protecting the seed genome. And this fellow in New York had decided that it may have some anti-cancer effects.
So we were testing the anti-cancer effect of Phytic acid in Syrian hamster embryo cells and a number of other tumor cell lines.
I was doing a lot of that work, the cell culture work. And that generated a few papers including papers that showed that Phytic acid seemed to affect cholesterol levels in animals and triglyceride levels in particular.
And also could inhibit metal-induced carcinogenesis in animals. We had a patent awarded for that particular work.
So Rexie was pretty well versed in cell culture and virology and carcinogenesis. And of course, in the 1980s being close to San Francisco everyone was well aware of this new syndrome
that was primarily affecting male homosexuals. Although there seemed to be, I think at that time, some incidents in hemophilia X2 who were undergoing blood transfusions. But the etiologic agent responsible for this age-aids-related arachia, I can't remember exactly what the sea stands for in that.
There was a syndrome that preceded overt AIDS. So people would, of course, it wasn't known that HIV was responsible for AIDS at that time.
So there's a lot of concern about AIDS, ARC, and how infectious this disease might be. And there was a lot of emphasis on things like drug use and sex habits
by male homosexuals that may contribute to immunodeficiency. So people weren't sure if it was a behavior, etiology, or whether there was some kind of pathogen involved.
And over time, of course, in the 1980s, it became clear from Montagne's work in France and also Gallos' work in the United States that, aha, there is actually an infectious agent here of virus that's probably responsible for causing AIDS.
And then cells were available that were infected with this virus, HIV. And we did, we're actually, did a lot of work with Steve Herike, who was from Lebanon, N-Line is Pauling,
looking at the effect of vitamin C added to the culture medium in which tea lymphocytes infected with HIV were grown.
So they wanted to find out whether vitamin C would have any effect on viability of the virus or replication of the virus.
And they found that it really affected viral replication, very potentally, dramatically inhibited viral replication.
And that was assayed by amounts of reverse transcriptase and also the formation of syncytia, which are abnormal cells that are sort of pathologic correlates of tea lymphocytes infection.
So that led to a paper that was published in PNAS with the three of them as authors. I think Pauling was a senior author and Gerowall was perhaps the first author.
And that paper presented the results of these cell culture experiments. It wasn't any clinical data, but they suggested that this might provide a promising approach for the treatment of AIDS, namely by that time AZT had been come available to for treatment of AIDS patients.
AZT is pretty effective at inhibiting the de novo infection of uninfected cells.
So you give AZT to patients and you preserve those uninfected cells from becoming infected with the virus.
So vitamin C prevents viral replication. So the idea was that if you give AZT and vitamin C, then you're inhibiting viral replication and you're protecting, if there is a little bit of viral replication, you're also inhibiting those new cells from becoming infected.
So the idea was that this might really, if it didn't eradicate the virus and kill the cells that were infected with the virus, at least it could cause AIDS to become a manageable disease, perhaps.
So what part of carrying involved?
Well, I think Cameron got involved because obviously there were medical issues involved here and he was Gerowall had a PhD, but didn't have a medical degree. The only other person at the institute, we had a veterinarian, Roger Barth, and Wolcott Dunham had an MD, and Wolcott was doing some work with guinea pigs and neural atherism at the time.
But he was pretty advanced in age at that time and was not physically very vigorous.
Cameron was still very vigorous and of course very interesting a lot of these issues, and I think through conversations with Gerowall and Paul and Cameron just naturally gravitated to that, especially once it had been demonstrated that vitamin C might have an important role to play there.
So what was the reaction to this research both in the scientific community and the public?
Well, I can't really say that I know what the reaction was in the scientific community.
I think by then maybe many people thought that Linus Pauling was going to just publish great stuff about vitamin C no matter what, and that we'd never find anything coming from the Pauling Institute that had anything to do with the negative effect of vitamin C.
Just so happens that all these experiments were positive.
So vitamin C is not snake oil, but it does have a lot of very important and interesting biochemical and physiological functions in the body and protecting against and treating different diseases.
So it's not a panacea, but it's a really remarkable substance and it's easy to see why Linus Pauling got so interested in it early on.
So I can't say what the professional reaction was.
I know that there were AIDS, there were doctors who treated AIDS patients who were very interested in our results.
In particular, there were several physicians from San Francisco General at the AIDS ward there who came down to the institute and gave seminars and were in contact with Pauling and Gerowell about this.
There was a lot of anecdotal evidence as well from San Francisco and New York and other major urban centers that had a lot of AIDS cases where some of the patients who were self-medicating with high dose oral vitamin C seemed to be doing a little bit better than their friends who were not taking high dose vitamin C.
But there weren't any controlled clinical studies at that time and I don't think to date there have been any controlled clinical trials on vitamin C and HIV infection or AIDS.
And of course the RCTs are most persuasive when it comes to adopting new strategies in medicine.
So absent RCTs, I think probably a lot of physicians just ignored it.
It's in the realm of anecdotal evidence. It really doesn't mean anything. It's just coincidence.
Yeah, vitamin C might have some value, but it's such a pedestrian substance and I'm sure that there are more promising biotherapies that we get involved in.
You can't completely disregard the political or financial perspectives in that whole debate either because a lot of physicians who are charged with running clinical trials to evaluate drugs stand a benefit from financially from the revenue stream should that drug turn out to be effective.
So a lot of people have tremendous incentive to study drug therapy and there's just not the same type of incentive with vitamin C.
But public reaction, I think varied. Of course people who were afflicted with AIDS or had friends who were afflicted with AIDS were quite interested and very appreciative of the institute's work.
Other people who were a little bit who felt for whatever moral reason that AIDS was a behavioral disease and that we shouldn't really waste money studying these problems that are due to behavior.
People would just change the behavior. We wouldn't have to worry about this. So some of those people withdrew support.
And again, as we saw after the negative male clinic studies on vitamin C and cancer, there was a lapse in some financial response to our direct male solicitation campaign.
But of course that never influenced the work that we undertook. I mean we undertook work that was fundable either from grants or contracts or from unrestricted funds that were available to us and be quests for the direct male program.
But I can't ever recall any discussion that suggested that any line of work at the institute should be stopped because it was a negative effect on either the media.
The media were down, were nullifying it or castigating it or donors were shying away because of that work.
So I think that kind of emulates Pauling's courageous attribute and not backing down if he felt he was right.
And I think the institute sort of adopted that same strategy. It's important research to do and we're not going to back down just because there's a lot of revenue.
You mentioned that Cameron and Pauling wrote a book about the subject that was going to publish, do you know why that is?
What I'm feeling is that they wrote the book without having talked to any publisher in advance to find out first of all if there was any interest in the book.
So they had no publishing contract and secondly I think the book was finished or nearly finished when Cameron became ill and I think his illness probably led him to pay less attention to it or be less excited about it.
What I inferred that, I don't know that for sure.
So we talked earlier about the vitamin C and cancer research and the perspective from within the institute the staff being generally on board and behind it.
I think it was at the stifus against the same degree vitamin C and age work as well.
I think so. I mean I never talked to anybody at the institute who expressed any scorn or negative feelings about that work.
The institute was relatively small and fairly collegial. I mean there were certain tensions and conflicts that developed over time of course from time to time as in any organization.
But I think people were very respectful of one another when it came to a science like that.
In 1989, Mattias Rat arrived at the institute and I'm wondering if you could share your first impressions of Rat?
Yeah, my first impressions were that he seemed like a very knowledgeable earnest fellow.
He clearly had developed some exciting ideas with Linus Pauling and it was great to see Linus Pauling enthused about the slip-up protein vitamin C story.
So my initial reactions were quite favorable.
I wasn't until I became aware of some other activities that seemed to be going on outside the purview of the institute, the Linus Pauling Heart Foundation and some other things which seemed to be a little obscure and not really conducted in a transparent way that people began to question motivation in particular.
Why are these other organizations being set up? What are they designed to do? Are they designed to compete with Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine as a complementary activity?
And because a lot of that kind of information wasn't forthcoming when you have kind of that black box, it generates lots of rumors and that's unfortunate.
And I think there was certainly some of that going around at the time. Although Linus Pauling also had been diagnosed with prostate cancer and Rat was providing some medical services for Pauling himself.
And I think everybody appreciated that. Here was somebody at the institute that Pauling was really interested in from a scientific standpoint and was also looking out for Pauling's physical welfare.
So I think initially everybody was quite enthused about this collaboration.
How do you characterize this personality that's...
Well, I think initially you seem to be very German. He didn't really seem to have a terribly great sense of humor.
It seemed to be very... I won't say solemn, but very serious-minded polite.
It seemed to treat people fairly.
Did he socialize with the rest of the being staff?
There was some socializing. There was throughout the history of the institute, different employees and groups of people would go out for dinners or lunch or go to bars on weekends or whatever.
And there was some of that kind of activity as well.
What was his research program that Pauling was excited about?
Well, Pauling of course had been long interested in vitamin C and cardiovascular disease. And he'd written about this in his book, How to Live Long and Feel Better.
He'd also written about it in articles for executive health, which was a tabloid type newsletter.
He'd also written about it for the Linus Point Institute Science and Medicine newsletter in the 1970s and 1980s, primarily in the 1980s.
So he had a long abiding interest in the possible value of vitamin C and preventing or treating heart disease.
Rat had some specific interest and data on the potential interaction between vitamin C and lipoprotein A, which is a major constituent of atherosclerotic plaque and also risk factor for heart disease.
The problem with lipoprotein A is that its levels in the blood don't seem to be amenable to modification by dietary or even drug strategy.
They're fairly genetically determined and they're very difficult to modulate.
So there's a lot of skepticism as to where the vitamin C could actually affect lipoprotein A levels in blood.
Rat had apparently some small set of clinical data that apparently showed that vitamin C might have value in decreasing lipoprotein A levels.
And I think that was very interesting to Pauling.
And then together they developed a hypothesis that lipoprotein A may serve as a surrogate for vitamin C in animals including people that do not synthesize vitamin C.
And there are some evidence that lipoprotein A levels in animals and people not synthesizing vitamin C were high and lipoprotein A levels seem to be low in the blood of those animals that were synthesizing vitamin C.
And that led them to think about, well what is lipoprotein A doing that vitamin C might otherwise do in the body.
And they believe that lipoprotein A might be synthesized by the body to contend with and repair fishers that develop in the vasculature due to oxidative damage or shear stress and other things of that nature.
So it might have a valuable role in repairing lesions but that because it's a very sticky molecule it could end up developing into atherosclerotic plaque.
And from the original hypothesis there were a number of corollaries that developed including the potential role of lysine in helping to either decrease plaque or keylate and remove lipoprotein A from the blood.
And Pauline published in the Journal of Worth Molecular Medicine in the early 1990s three case reports of people who had suffered from severe angina, exercised induced angina, who had had very serious cardiovascular disease bypass and other surgical interventions and still had angina.
And they read Pauline's papers with RAF and decided to try adding lysine to their regimen.
In some cases these people had already been taking fairly high doses of vitamin C and then added lysine.
They weren't controlled studies so these were reported as anecdotes and the amount of lysine and vitamin C was quite variable.
But it was on the order of three to six grams per day of each and they reported fairly rapid relief from angina.
So Pauline speculated that perhaps because the relief was so rapid that lysine might even bind to lipoprotein A in plaque and help remove it from plaque and that was possibly explaining why these people were not suffering from angina because the thickness of the plaque was decreasing.
Well it turns out subsequent research has revealed that vitamin C has very important effects in vasodilation and sort of improving blood flow in people with atherosclerotic plaque through its effects on tetrahedral biopter which is involved in synthesis of nitric oxide which improves blood flow.
But the role of lysine in this process is still obscure and I don't think other than Pauline's hypothesis I don't think there's been much speculation as to why lysine in particular might have had this benefit.
Because as I mentioned some of the people that were reported in these case studies had already been taking very high dose vitamin C without presumably any benefit yet when they added lysine there seemed to be a fairly dramatic effect.
So that I thought was a very, it's an interesting area and probably a rich area for research although as far as I know no one's really looked into it.
So those were some of the ideas that Pauline and Wrath were developing in that period that I think were exciting to everybody.
And as I came to understand the Linus-Pong Heart Foundation was specifically set up to raise money to support clinical trials on some of these potential therapies including proline lysine, vitamin C, niacin and so forth.
We'll talk more about Wrath here in a second. There's a couple of things that happen chronologically that I want to touch on first. In 1999 there was a rezoning effort in Palo Alto in which time of the city gave the Institute three years to move basically.
All right. What was the reaction to that and how did you start applying for that?
Well, that was very interesting. That was about the same time that Emil Zucacondle and Rick Hicks retired from the Linus-Pong Institute of Science and Medicine and set up the Institute for Molecular Medical Sciences.
And we leased them space within the facility at 440 Page Mill Road to do that. So that was a very contentious time.
Emil and Rick Hicks left the Institute. Emil still had strong interest in preserving a research program and yet didn't have a lot of funding available to him.
So Pauling wanted us to find out whether or not us meeting Stephen Maddox myself and Z Kerman to find out whether this was practical and feasible to subtly space.
And Linus-Pong Jr was involved in that as well, to subtly space to IMMS within the building and how the building might be partitioned and how equipment might be made available to IMMS or how they could share equipment and so on and so forth.
So that was kind of a contentious time at the Institute but resulted in a sub-least IMMS because we found a way to make everything work to everyone's satisfaction.
And at about that time I had become executive officer of the Institute and was working very closely with Linus-Pong Jr.
Because Linus-Pauling Sr. was undergoing treatment for cancer and still had problems in structural chemistry and theoretical chemistry and orthomolecular medicine that he really wanted to devote his time to.
So Linus-Pong Jr. and the board decided to free his father from administrative responsibilities and Linus-Pong Jr. would sort of step in as president or director of the Institute and I would assist him.
And initially I was asked by Linus-Pauling to assist him and then later when it became clear that he wasn't really interested in exercising any administrative responsibility.
Linus-Pong Jr. stepped in and then I worked very closely with Linus-Pauling Jr.
And that was my first understanding of the fact that the Institute had this zoning problem and apparently it had been known for a long time but nobody had really done much about it.
So Linus-Pauling Jr. and I and the board realized that absent an endowment and a lot of money it was really going to be difficult for us to sustain the Institute as a viable biomedical research organization if we had to move.
Because we had a very favorable leasing arrangement with our landlords the cost of the lease went up only adjusted by CPI, the Consumer Price Index.
So we were paying I think 50 or 55 cents a square foot for 20,000 plus square foot building in Palo Alto.
And to move we would have been looking at probably 5, 6, 7, 8, 10, $12 a square foot.
So the prospect of moving was not very satisfying because it meant that we would be spending much more money on just simply renting a facility and not have much money available to pay staff, recruit or do research.
So that was not an appealing option at all. Yet we were suddenly aware that we had three years and we really had to leave because the master plan in Palo Alto called for changing the mix of commercial and residential properties because they were becoming very concerned that there weren't enough residential units for people that worked in Palo Alto.
And it's kind of a I don't want to go off on a tangent but I had long discussions with city planners, city staff, the planning committee for Palo Alto and some of the council members and my opinion at the time was well that's fine.
You can build condominiums or apartment buildings here but there's no way you can ensure that the people who rent or buy these condos or apartment buildings are going to work in Palo Alto because Palo Alto is a very desirable address.
People might move here and work in Sunnyvale or San Francisco or Hayward or the East Bay or the South Bay and you're just going to increase traffic and it's going to become not necessarily the outcome that you're striving for with this zoning change.
But be that as it may, we really had to face the inevitable which was the zoning was going to change.
And so I decided that it was imperative to delay that until we could really come up with a proper solution for the institute's future.
And taking a page out of Linus Pauling and Eva Helen's book, we set up folding tables around town outside grocery stores and cafes and had petitions.
And I can't remember the exact wording of the petition but it was something to the effect.
Please sign the petition if you'd like to see the institute stay at its location in Palo Alto if you feel that we're doing good work and so on and so forth.
We had quite a few names signed in those petitions and they were eventually delivered to the city council and I made a presentation in the city council.
Linus Pauling made a presentation in the city council and eventually we squeaked through with city council approval to delay that zoning change for a period of time because they recognized that we were doing valuable work and that we really needed more time to chart a proper course for the future.
And as one of the Palo Alto city council members mentioned, she didn't want to read the New York Times that the city of Palo Alto had kicked the Linus Pauling Institute out of town.
That's interesting I had never heard that before.
Yeah so that was a very successful campaign and I should mention that during these city council meeting appearances, you know I felt well it's good and fine for me to go and talk to the city council and I had met all of the city council members individually and pleaded our case to them.
And they seemed to be favorably disposed to the institute although some of them were wavering somewhat.
And I figured that I could make a pretty compelling argument in front of the city council during public testimony, but I thought it would really sent you to line as Pauling himself could appear and I asked him if he would be willing to do that and he said yes so he went with me to the city council meeting.
And it just so happened that that meeting of the city council where they were scheduled to vote on this issue was the first appearance by Gearhart Casper who was president of Stanford University.
And there was a tradition where the president of the university would go and make I think on an annual basis of state of the university address to the city council.
Because Stanford is adjacent to the city of Palo Alto and they have a lot of mutual interest and mutual conflicts.
So the city is always interested in finding out what Stanford's doing and Stanford's always interested in finding out what the city is planning so Gearhart Casper was there to spend 20 minutes or so giving his address to the city council.
And as Pauling walked in and the chambers were full of people who were waiting to give testimony, Gearhart Casper recognized Pauling and ran over to him in the two of them exchange pleasantries they'd never met before.
And Gearhart Casper who I believe was scheduled before me or before Pauling on the agenda spent quite a lot of his a lot of time talking about what a wonderful person line as Pauling was.
Talked about it Stanford, there are many Nobel Prize winners, there are so many that they really don't turn heads anymore except for Linus Pauling.
Because Linus Pauling was such an outstanding scholar and such an outstanding piece activist and scientist that when Pauling was there, heads did turn.
And I thought it was quite nice of Casper to talk about Pauling in those glowing terms and Casper is a lawyer.
So he didn't really have professionally much exposure to Linus Pauling's work in science but nevertheless he recognized that Pauling was a really eminent scientist and really wanted to pay tribute to him.
So that kind of cinched the case for us I think and also there was a fellow in the audience who stood up and introduced himself by name and said that he felt Pauling's work was very important and the institute's work was very important
and really wanted to encourage the city council to delay the zoning change.
And at the end of the meeting when we were waiting I was with Pauling and the underground garage waiting for the card to come around and Pauling mentioned to me that he remembered that fellow who gave public testimony.
He was a student of his at Caltech and he remembered an incident with him and said that when he was teaching he had the socratic method of teaching where he would pick out.
People to answer questions because the classes were apparently small enough he knew all the students were new their names.
So during one of his chemistry lectures he had a question and he picked this fellow out to answer the question and the fellow proceeded to give an answer that was really not the right answer but I guess he felt compelled to say something.
So Pauling just nodded and thanked him for the response and at the end of the class Pauling went up to him and said I'd like to talk with you for a moment and Pauling said you know it's perfectly okay when you don't know the answer to a question to admit that and so you don't know the answer.
Actually it's far better than confabulating but I thought it was rather amazing that Pauling remembered that particular incident and this particular fellow who I'm sure he hadn't thought about or seen for decades.
Backtracked him real quick I was interested to hear that when Zooka Kamalash the pigs went with him.
Yeah Zooka Kamal and Hicks were good friends and allies and they'd worked very very closely together and had actually sacrificed a lot for the institute.
Emil had loaned the institute money gone without salary or decreased salary and Rick Hicks had been also very self-sacrificing trying to help the institute progress over the years.
So I think Rick felt when Emil's contract was not renewed that he would leave as well and so both of them left but Hicks was then voted to join the Board of Trustees.
Of the Linus Plains II Science and Medicine which I thought was a terrific collegial and important move for the Board of Trustees to make because Hicks had a lot of insight into fundraising for the institute and just a lot of knowledge and insight about the institute in general and I thought it would be very important for him to be associated in a continued way with the institute.
So I thought that was a very good strategic move to ask Rick to become part of the Board.
And Emil of course had his hands full with trying to administer and get his new institute Institute of Molecular Medical Sciences off the ground.
And Emil had actually wanted me as well as a number of other people, Jim Fleming and Greg Spicer and Teddy Bulacoss and other people who were doing more molecular biological work.
It was not really directly allied with orthomolecular medicine.
For instance, Greg Spicer was doing work in molecular evolution. Jim Fleming was doing work in molecular bases of aging.
Teddy Bulacoss was working on histones and DNA repair and a lot of those programs didn't really fit into the orthomolecular scope of the institute.
And when the institute was reorganized when Hicks and Zucacondle left, the Board decided to refocus the limited resources on orthomolecular medicine.
So they wanted to have a much more narrow focus and kind of pair away some of those programs that were not closely allied with that mission because we just could not afford to do everything.
And those programs that were being paired away, Emil hoped to collect in this new organization Institute of Molecular Medical Sciences.
And he did, to some extent, did that pretty successfully.
So this divergence in the research engine that was the primary reason for it to be able to departure from the institute?
What? The divergence in the research agenda was his primary reason for leaving?
Yeah, my understanding was that the Board was very concerned about income and outgo.
So the Board had become increasingly concerned over the late 1980s about the cost of all the programs at the institute and the variable fundraising success.
The Cessicaua donation $500,000 a year for 10 years was coming to an end and couldn't be renewed due to their charter stipulations.
So it was difficult to find money to support some of this work that was not grant funded and a lot of it was not grant funded.
The years of Yurka had a nice grant from the Department of Energy that was funding his work on allu sequences and non-conserved and conserved DNA and so forth.
But a meals program that I was involved in looking at metastatic cancer, Greg Spicer's work, some of the other work was really not funded except through unrestricted funds to the institute.
So the Board decided to ask a meal to shrink the institute so that the expenses would be more aligned with the actual revenue instead of continuing to grow the institute
and allowing it to continue at what they considered an infeasible size and I think a meal didn't want to do that.
So rather than do something that he didn't want to do, I think he resigned and with him went where he kicks.
We talked about Cameron's illness and in 1991 he died. I'm wondering if he treated himself at all with some of the techniques that he had to advocate for some of the people in court.
Yeah, that's very interesting. I had asked Cameron about his own habits with vitamin C supplementation much earlier before he became sick and he said that he was taking little vitamin C but not taking mega doses because he thought that should he ever get ill
that he wanted to reserve those mega doses for therapeutic value. I think he probably took some vitamin C but as far as I know he never himself took intravenous vitamin C and again the differential response to people getting intravenous vitamin C and oral vitamin C was not well characterized at that time.
It was clear that some of the patients getting IV vitamin C did very well but also if you go back and look at the historical record Cameron's patient pool.
Some of those early patients that had complete necrosis of tumors got only oral vitamin C and the tumor necrosis was a consequence temporally of that high dose oral vitamin C.
So I think Cameron and others believe that oral vitamin C had some anti cancer effects as well, although much later of course these transport molecules for vitamin C were discovered and this was after Cameron Pauling had both died.
These discoveries were made so now we have a better understanding of the limitations of achieving high concentration of vitamin C in the blood when you take it only orally but in those days that wasn't well known.
So Cameron may have felt and I never talked to him about this but he may have felt that since some of his patients did quite well apparently on oral vitamin C that may be intravenous vitamin C was not important for him.
But he also at the end of his illness became less willing to see friends and colleagues.
So there were many occasions when Zellik Herman and Zellik's girlfriend and I would go to Connie Cameron's house in Redwood City and Ewan was not well enough to see visitors.
So we would sit and chat with Connie Cameron and offer her solace and ask her to pass on our good wishes to Ewan but he clearly was not feeling well enough to see visitors.
What was the impact of this death on the Institute?
Well Ewan was such a charismatic and wonderful man that it really had a big impact on people personally.
I recall his memorial service in Redwood City, Zellik Herman's girlfriend played bagpipes and it was just an incredibly emotional event.
People were really grieving about Cameron's death and of course Pauling was there and Rat was there as well.
Everybody felt terrible about Cameron's death.
In 1992 Mattias Rat was appointed vice president for financial affairs at the Institute. How did this come about?
That's a good question. That was 1992, you say?
This was after Cameron's death so Cameron was probably Pauling's closest collaborator in Zellik Herman of course as well.
When Rat arrived with these ideas about cardiovascular disease and lipoprotein and vitamin C and he and Pauling started working very closely on this collaboration,
I think that sort of took center stage in Pauling's life and although he remained committed to some of the problems that he was working with with Zellik Herman,
I think his bond with Rat was getting stronger and stronger and I think Pauling may have unilaterally made that decision to give that appointment to Rat because he had no reason not to trust him.
Clearly I think Pauling and Rat perceived perhaps a new focus for research in the Institute which would be vitamin C and heart disease especially now that there was this reinvigoration of this focus on orthomolecular medicine.
So I think that perhaps it seemed logical that Rat would be involved there because they also had set up the heart foundation and other organizations to try to raise money specifically for these clinical trials.
So how did things start to unravel with him?
Well I think Rat did a number of things that upset Pauling and caused some consternation that was kind of a political strategy in the scientific realm which sometimes can work and sometimes can backfire.
And I remember there was one meeting I believe in Texas, I can't remember the specific society but it was cardiovascular disease, researchers and physicians.
And Rat had Xerox something and put it on every seat in the auditorium for everybody to read and Rat was also developing these ideas about big pharma trying to suppress or inhibit work on orthomolecular medicine.
And I think a lot of people share those opinions to some degree.
And Rat just seemed to be using more of a political strategy to advance the research agenda.
And some of those things were done I think Pauling felt and others felt maybe not in an entirely appropriate manner.
I remember seeing one press release that Rat had written and Pauling had written all over it that it was really unwise and uncalled for, had nothing new to announce.
And I think Linus Pauling was starting to worry a little bit about the trust that he placed in Rat.
So at some point when that fundraising or executive vice president position was, I think Rat resigned or that position was eliminated.
Stephen Maddox became vice president for finance or fundraising or whatever the particular title was.
So he sort of succeeded Rick Hicks after an interlude there with Matthias Rath being in that position for a while.
And Linus Pauling Jr. and I became increasingly concerned about Rath and his activities.
And we also became aware of the fact that Rath had not signed the patent agreement.
And it was incumbent upon every employee as an obligation of employment to sign a patent agreement.
And the patent agreement was actually quite generous when people joined corporations as employees they typically surrender all their rights to the company.
And many people can invent and discover wonderful things for companies and not see a dime.
Academic institutions it handled a little bit differently and in our organization which was modeled after an academic institution it was fairly generous to inventors.
So the idea was that if you discover something that may be patentable in the course of your employment at the institute, you can bring that to the institutes administration and decision we had a patent committee at the time.
And a decision can be made as to whether the institute would like to pursue this, file the, you know, get the initiate the patent application process.
Or if the institute did not want to pursue it then they would surrender it to you and you could pursue it at your own expense and you would have the patent and you could go ahead and license it and if there's a revenue stream that would be solely yours.
So the patent agreement stipulated should the institute proceed to try to gain a patent for this invention or discovery that should it be licensed, the revenue would be split between the inventor and the institute and the following percentages.
And everybody had signed that, Linus Pauling had signed that himself and Rath refused to sign it.
I think initially he said he would like to think about it and I think the choice was given to him.
Well, you know, you really obligated as an employee to sign this and if you don't want to sign it then perhaps you should think about resigning.
So he asked for some time to think about that and said fine.
And a day or two later he said that he wanted to quit and wanted to resign and he did.
What was the source of the litigation that he filed against the institute?
How did that arise?
Well he resigned and I really had no interest or, I mean I had my hands full with trying to solve a lot of the financial and personnel and research problems at the institute
to think about where the institute should go in the future and Linus planks health and all these other myriad problems that we were facing.
So I really didn't keep up with what Rath was doing because he resigned from the institute he was gone.
I didn't really honestly care about what he was doing.
And it wasn't until maybe a year or so later that we were served with a lawsuit and he had set up a company called HealthNow Incorporated.
And this company was suing Linus Pauling and the Linus Pauling Institute of Science in Medicine for interference with its business activities.
And the gist of the suit was that Rath apparently had been trying to get to forge business relationships with supplement companies.
And he was bringing to them these ideas about vitamin C and heart disease and lysine and so forth presumably to formulate new products or whatever.
And according to the suit he had met with discouragement from some of these company representatives because they didn't know who he was.
And they would point to news stories about Linus Pauling and vitamin C and cardiovascular disease or heart health.
And in many of those stories Rath's name was omitted.
Not because Pauling failed to give him credit because Pauling I think was very fair and egalitarian about that.
And would always mention Rath when he talked to journalists or media about these ideas in lipoprotein A and vitamin C and heart disease, atherosclerosis.
But because Rath was kind of an unknown quantity and really had no reputation to speak of, and I'm just inferring this, media often would drop his name and the focus would be on Linus Pauling.
And I think Rath found that very frustrating and discouraging because he perceived that lack of credit interfering with his ability to make these business relationships with different supplement companies.
And so he found an attorney and decided to file suit against the institute.
And that led to actually his complaint was dismissed, essentially.
But we filed a cross complaint because in the course of this litigation he had made a lot of statements that we felt were injurious to our activities.
At the time we were trying to forge a relationship with Elizabeth Arden and Unilever Corporation.
We were interested in developing a line of cosmetic products that would include things like vitamin C and antioxidants and phytochemicals.
And they wanted to support some research at the institute and get involved with the institute in interesting ways.
And Rath had started to communicate with these people telling them that we were unreliable business partners and so on and so forth and that he owned all these rights.
And so we felt compelled to sue him to stop interfering with our business relationships.
And during the course of this litigation Rath alluded to some agreements that he had executed with Linus Pauling that he claimed gave him all kinds of rights that we weren't aware of.
So Linus Paul and Jr. and I were bewildered by this and we went to the documents that Dorothy Monroe pulled out of file for us and she showed us these agreements that look like had been written by Rath and signed by Pauling.
And then in some cases witnessed by a third party and they had to do with Rath's rights essentially.
And we were very surprised by these documents.
They didn't seem to be proper and we took them to Linus Pauling and showed them to him and asked him if he had any memory of these documents or the circumstances under which he signed them.
And he looked at them very carefully and was confused about them and read them and said well that certainly looks like my name.
I believe that that's my signature but I don't recall the content of this document at all and now that I read it I would not have signed it.
So we tried to reconstruct why Linus Pauling signed these documents and we came to the impression and again it's hard to verify this independently.
It can't be verified independently but based on statements that Dorothy Monroe and others made we came to the opinion that Rath had gotten Pauling to sign these documents when he was executive vice president and may have gone into Pauling's office with a whole sheath of documents for Pauling to execute.
And these documents were probably among those papers and Pauling just signed them without reading them carefully.
And it turned out in the consequence of litigation the documents that Pauling had signed giving Rath lots of rights and ownership were nullified for lack of compensation.
So how is all the litigation involved? Well the litigation was resolved you know typically the court really encourages you to come to a settlement.
And there are settlement conferences set up by the court to get the parties together to hash out a settlement because the court really doesn't want to get involved in litigation unless it's absolutely necessary.
So they have retired judges who mediate these settlement conferences and the retired judge seems to have the strategy of keeping people in a room until they give up a weird hat and settle.
And it's a strategy I think that works pretty often. So we had a number of settlement conferences and eventually rather than going through a trial Rath suit against us had been dismissed.
So the only remaining issue was our suit against him across complaint, excuse me for libel and judicious info what was it called interference with our business relationships I can't remember the exact terminology.
So that was what was on the table to settle the suit against health now and Rath. So we came to a settlement that we were satisfied with.
We Rath was supposed to pay us I believe $75,000. We were not to disparage his activities he would not disparage our activities mutual non disparagement.
And we assigned him some patents that he basically had done the work on so we felt we would be fine to give him those patents.
We didn't really expect them to generate any income anyway. And that was the gist of the settlement by and large and Rath never paid the $75,000.
So we mentioned a little bit over the course of this interview.
The role that Linus pointed you played and essentially inserting himself and dealing with some of the administrative issues that his father was either disinterested or unable to do because of his advancing age and declining health.
I wonder if you could comment a little bit on sort of last year's arrival at the institute and the role that he played in those last few years of his father's life.
Yeah, well when the staff became aware of the fact that there were problems or financial problems.
So sometimes in the very early 1990s and then when Pauline had been diagnosed and disclosed his disease publicly, there was quite a lot of anxiety I would say because people really weren't sure what was going to happen to them to the research programs,
to the institute. And there was just a lot of unease among the staff.
And the board I think recognized this and realized that they had to do something specific and concrete and make some very definite steps and kind of clarify all the ambiguity and gossip that was going around and kind of put it into the gossip and really lay things out.
Here's where the status is now and here's where we're going to go in the future.
And Linus Plung Jr. had been a board member right from the early days at the institute but I think he recognized that his father was unwilling or unable to resolve some of these issues in a really meaningful way.
So he decided to assert himself more in the role of the board.
So he decided or I guess with the board and his father's acknowledgement, he became chairman of the board of trustees and Linus Pauline became director of research I think at that time too.
So because Pauline was essentially directing a lot of the research at the institute anyway.
So he was director of research Linus Plung Jr. I believe became chairman of the board and then at some point in there I moved from becoming executive officer to chief executive officer.
And because Linus Plung Jr. was chairman of the board and we have lots of problems and I had very little experience in large scale administration.
I had been administering a relatively small research group with a little bit of fundraising activity and a little bit of public relations.
I frequently gave tours to the two people who visited the institute and wanted to learn about our science so I had some skills there I guess or some experience at least.
And Linus Plung Jr. and I started to work very closely together.
So I had really seen him before but I had never really worked intensively with him until he sort of took over management for his father in those early days nearly part of the decade there.
And I found him to be very a very reasonable, forceful, thoughtful person.
And I really appreciated his skill and essentially wisdom in addressing some of these issues that face the institute.
He seemed to have a pretty good way of analyzing some of the problems and together we worked up strategies to solve some of the issues that we were facing.
Was it all in touch with the institute of the rival and his assumption of this role?
I don't think so because I think most people realized that Linus Plung was not going to be an effective administrator of the institute at that stage.
So somebody needed to put their hand on the rudder of the ship and start to exercise some direction.
And I think people were, I mean I can't say what everybody's reaction was about me becoming chief executive officer because that was an unusual move.
I didn't have an advanced degree, although I had been co-directing a relative with small research group and there were other people with seniority that one could have predicted would have been asked to become chief executive officer.
I'm not quite sure why I was asked but honestly I was a little flattered and I felt very stimulated by the challenge of becoming chief executive officer learning more about what problems the institute faced and how to solve them because I always considered myself a bit of a problem solver and here was a whole set of what seemed to be very, very serious problem.
So I'm not sure I would have taken the job and you know if I'd known when they asked me to become CEO, the magnitude of the problems that the institute faced but I'm glad I did.
What was the biggest challenge in hindsight for you in assuming that role?
Well the biggest problem, the biggest immediate problem was funding and it was heartbreaking for me to lay off people that I had worked with and for for very, very long time.
Absolutely heartbreaking. I literally had tears in my eyes when I was telling people that there was no longer a job for them at the institute but it was a fact of life and it was sort of my first exposure to what it's like to be in charge and make unpopular decisions or decisions that you don't want to make as a person but you're obligated to make because of the role that you're playing in an organization.
So it was difficult too.
A couple more questions for today. One event in the institute that seemed to come at exactly the right time was the donation to the estate of Carl Spodner.
Yes, yes.
Can you give any background on this? This is something that seems to provide a bit of a lifeline for the institute and most needed it.
That's right. And as a matter of fact I remarked to a meal because a meal had already decided at that time that he was leaving.
There was kind of a bittersweet news for a meal because on the one hand you know this was the salvation financial salvation for the institute but other decisions had already been made.
So it came a little too late in some regard.
Spodner to the best of my understanding had been a donor to the institute for quite a long time, very small amounts of money.
And at the time the institute did not have access to a lot of research capability to investigate donors based on tax filings or real estate holdings or zip code or anything like that.
These days it's very sophisticated kind of donor research that philanthropic organizations or foundations can do to find out really who among their constituents have the ability to make large gifts of one sort or another.
Back then we didn't really have that ability so there was no way of targeting people who were giving small donations to the institute for cultivation for instance.
And the other kinds of fundraising strategies that might be developed to encourage people to give money.
So it was a big surprise when we were notified about this estate that had lots of different aspects to it.
I believe there was an office building and a home and gold coins and money and just a lot of different financial instruments within this estate.
And it really did allow us to pay off some of the debts to trustees who had loaned the institute money and to kind of get on an even keel a bit.
And we also within a couple of years became aware of another big request, the Phineas state, which also helped us establish enough money so that we could have an endowment that would make the institute more attractive to a college or university.
To which we might move and it allowed us to bring $1.5 million at least to Oregon State University when we moved up here in 1996 to endow the director's position.
And at that time there was a match in the state so there was a functional $3 million endowment, which was really a good endowment to attract top caliber scientists for this directorship of the Linus-Bong Institute.
But getting back to the Phineas state, the Phineas donation was sometime in the early 1990s, maybe 93 through 94 or 5, I don't really remember the exact date.
At that time I was also negotiating contracts with Elizabeth Arden that I expected would produce a very considerable revenue stream for the institute for a very conceivably quite a long time.
And that to me looked like it might be the financial salvation for the institute and allow the institute to remain as an independent biomedical organization and recruit and attract top caliber scientists.
But that was still under negotiation and under development and we weren't quite sure where that was going to go.
I got a phone call from a woman in New Jersey, I believe, who said that she wanted to know if I was aware of her name was Catherine Phineas, not quite sure what her first name was, but this woman had been her best friend and was aware of the last will and testament and told me that she herself had been named as the beneficiary in the will and was to receive a condominium.
And the institute was to receive most of the financial instruments that were available in the in the estate and then I think there was small donations elsewhere, but it was a fairly large amount of money, several million dollars.
And the woman told me that Phineas had been deteriorating in recent months and a caregiver had come to live with her.
And this caregiver apparently had persuaded Phineas to alter her will and leave everything to him.
And the woman who called me thought that this was really unethical and unjust and that this person had exploited a deteriorating woman to his own financial gain.
And it sure seemed that way to me. I didn't know what the facts of the case were, but I hired a firm in New Jersey to look into it and it resulted in a nice settlement for the institute where we got a belief several million dollars.
The caretaker ended up with several hundred thousand dollars and the woman who brought this to our attention ended up with her condominium.
What happened to the Elizabeth Arden relationship?
The Elizabeth Arden relationship was quite promising. I was really excited by that because there was a research element to it.
They were quite interested in funding research that would find out if vitamin C and other micronutrients or phytochemicals could protect skin cells, caretinocytes from damage by sun exposure.
Because they were starting to develop cosmetic, topical, cosmetic products that included these micronutrients.
And they also had some preliminary data from their own labs that suggested that topical application of vitamin C and other substances improve the appearance of the skin.
And I think from a marketing standpoint, they were excited about getting involved with the institute because as the director of research told me,
their facility was in Trumble Connecticut. He's the one who really got in contact with us and asked us if we were interested in working with them in this regard.
He said, you know, we started thinking about vitamin C. Well, who really knows the most about vitamin C? Well, it's Linus Pauling. I should contact the Linus Pauling Institute.
And he did. And we decided because the prospect of revenue was so great or the prospect of a lot of revenue was so great that it wasn't something that we should just take lightly or dismiss.
So we spent a lot of time thinking about this and analyzing it. And we were, some of the trustees were concerned about the commercial exploitation of the name Linus Pauling.
And they thought, you know, perhaps if the product bombs and we're associated with it, that maybe it will tarnish our reputation.
But we worked out an agreement where we had review of all the marketing literature that Arden and Unilever would produce.
And they could make certain factual statements about what they were doing at the institute supporting a research project and so forth.
And that we were not engaged in researching development with Arden looking to formulate new products with Arden.
That wasn't something that was part of this arrangement or relationship.
And then we agreed to produce a joint newsletter that would be translated into many different languages and available at point of sale in high end departments towards around the world.
And we did that one newsletter which featured an interview with Linus Pauling.
Lester Packer also had an article in that and some information about the institute because I saw this as a way of expanding our base of constituents because if we could introduce the institute and its activities to younger people or middle age people that shop at these high end department stores presumably they have high income.
That they might get interested in supporting the institute's research and may at some point in the distant future decide to give us requests as well if they thought the work we were doing was good.
So I thought this was a good way to expand the institute's influence, get more public education about what we were doing and generate revenue for the institute.
And in addition to that exposure there was also a financial element where we would gain financially from the sale of some of their products and this looked to be remarkably large magnitude of money for us, really staggering amount of money possibly.
And everything was great. I went to Hamburg, Germany and to New York City and Toronto and participated in press conferences. The marketing materials were all developed. The product line was about to be launched.
And the president of Elizabeth Arden Bob Phillips at the time left Arden to take a job with Unilever in London which was the parent company of Elizabeth Arden.
And they hired a new president from Chicago and this new president came in and proceeded to turn the company upside down, suspended a lot of the research contracts except for ours, suspended a lot of the marketing efforts for new products and things like that.
Unfortunately, although everybody had expectations for great success because of this management change at Arden, it really interfered with the rollout of all these products and marketing strategies and everything else.
She left the company after a year and it took them a couple of years after that to fully recover.
So needless to say, our high hopes were somewhat dashed there because of management issues at Elizabeth Arden.
And they never followed up on it in many years afterwards.
They may have, you know, I don't really follow the cosmetics industry so I don't know what they did subsequently but the relationship with the institute eventually came to an end.
And they continued to provide money, you know, because we had a contract, we had a contract with Elizabeth Arden and we had a sub license from LC Progeny to use the name Linus Pauling and so we could use that name in our association or contractual association with Elizabeth Arden.
And they were funding a research project, as I mentioned, that was transferred to LPI at Oregon State.
So the funding continued for some time and then eventually that project funding ran out and then that was the end of the relationship.
But they also underwrote our newsletter and they provided, I was talking to John McCook who was the vice president for research at Arden.
And after Pauling's death, I brought up with him the prospect of doing a very nice commemorative issue of the newsletter that would pay tribute specifically to Linus Pauling.
And he thought that was a terrific idea and we didn't have the money to produce anything really nice ourselves, high volume.
So Arden very graciously underwrote the commemorative booklet that we produced in lieu of a fall newsletter in 1994 after Linus Pauling died.
That's the blue one that we have now.
So the last question for today is August of 94, Linus Pauling dies. How would you characterize this date at the Institute of Point?
Well it was a terrible day. I mean it was a day that we knew was inevitable but you never want to get that news even when you know you should be expecting it.
It was a summer day, a beautiful day in Palo Alto. Pauling had been at his ranch in Big Sur and Celic Herman and I and some other people had been down to see him.
There was a deposition actually of Pauling I believe earlier that summer by our attorneys that we went down for.
But I didn't have any direct knowledge of his deterioration or health status.
I knew that he wasn't doing really well but I didn't really have any firsthand knowledge of what he was doing there.
So we had worked up in obituary based on information available to us from his biography and from Paredewski's work and probably from materials that were available to us from special collections.
So we had an obituary ready to go and of course this was as I said before the internet so the obituary was to be faxed upon notification of Pauling's death.
So it had been a typically difficult day at the Institute for me. It was always challenging in those days with litigation and financial problems and thinking about the future disposition of the Institute and so forth.
I remember going home that day in August and I had a couple of beers before dinner and I got a call from Linus Pine Jr.
Before I had a chance to eat and Linus Pine Jr. told me that his father had just died and it really hit me hard because I was kind of surprised at my own emotional reaction because I really love Linus Pine.
It's just an amazing person. So immediately I got back in my car and went back to the Institute and I started faxing these obituraries which I had a stack of obituraries with media contact numbers.
So they went to CBS, New York Times, NBC, excuse me, CNN, whatever the media contacts we had I'd sent them out.
San Francisco Chronicles, San Jose Mercury, there were probably 15 or 20 of these to be faxed out.
So no sooner had I faxed the third out and the phone started ringing.
And in those days we had an old-fashioned phone system where you could see a number of little pegs that would light up for an incoming line.
And I think that there were as many as six incoming lines. So you could look at a single phone and see six of these clear pegs and a peg would be lit depending upon what the incoming number was.
And at first, through the third fax there was one of these little pegs that lit up. So I answered it while I was continuing to fax and it was newsweek or something.
And they wanted some pithy quotes about the life of Linus Pine. And it wasn't difficult for me but it really took some effort to hold myself together to give them cogent statements about Linus Pine because I was feeling really sad.
And I was manically trying to fax all these obituaries out. And before long, every light was lit and blinking. And it was the New York Times, it was CBS, it was everybody under the sun wanted statements.
So I spent the better part of that early evening there responding to all these phone calls for more information.
And then the next day, of course, everybody at the institute knew that Linus Pine had died. And there was a lot of grief and people were crying. And it was a really difficult time for everybody.
In terms of the footing of the institute itself though at that point, how would you characterize it? I mean the name sake of the institute is just died. And what is what the other for the organization at that point?
Yeah, we had, of course, in the Board of Trustees meetings, which we had very regularly, by the way. And then we had reports that went out to the board every month because there were so many problems. And we wanted everything to be done as perfectly as possible.
So I would write a report to the Board of Trustees every month and send it off to all of them by fax. And that would cover all the personnel issues, financial issues. I would have the accountant give us a status of our bank accounts, investments and so forth.
So that everybody knew all the time exactly where we were. And of course, we took very seriously the problem of leaving the building in Palo Alto.
And Linus Pauling had expressed the desire. I think his, his first priority was for the institute to remain independent because I thought I think he felt that we could probably be unswayed by mainstream medicine or mainstream science if we retained independence.
We could be more iconoclastic and more of a maverick organization. But absent that, he completely supported the idea of integrating into an appropriate university with academic activities that would resonate with the institute's mission.
So who was supportive of that, but he died before the discussions with Oregon State University had really matured.
We had lots of people coming to the institute presenting different options to us ideas about what they would do in the institute, should we transfer funds to them and the name and so on and so forth.
There was one fellow who was a relocation specialist who had contacted me who had a lot of contacts with universities around the country.
And thanks to his good graces, we initiated discussions with university administrators in Wisconsin and Boston University in Oklahoma.
A lot of different places to find out if there was any interest in the Linus Buying Institute.
So all those conversations, and to be honest with you, so many things were happening in that short period of time.
I can't really place everything chronologically, but Pauling was certainly aware of the desire that the board had to keep the institute going as a working tribute to his ideas in orthomolecular medicine.
And there were different options being discussed. One, for instance, was I think this was brought up by one of our trustees. Maybe what we should do is just close the institute down, liquidate everything and take that money and establish a chair in Linus Buying's name at Caltech.
Caltech or Stanford or someplace like that that would be most meaningful to Linus Pauling.
So there were lots of different possibilities that were pretty seriously discussed at those days.
But financially you had a couple pretty big gifts that came and then basically kept you above water for a little while.
That's right. And that really improved the probability of securing the interest of an academic institution too.
One problem that we confronted with lots of universities was that they just didn't have a lot of vacant space.
Vacant space doesn't exist in the university environment. I mean, it's subsumed by departments or units right away.
So there wasn't a lot of existing space in any of the universities that we talked with where we could just walk right in and make ourselves at home.
And people have different impressions of the reputation of the institute.
So, you know, there are always people that believe that Pauling was flaky with the vitamin C and orthomolecular medicine.
And there were probably institutions that shared that attitude as well.
So, we recognized that any institution who was looking to gain the Linus Plain Institute would also be gaining perhaps a little bit of a risk as well.
And the litigation, you know, had been covered in the papers. So, you know, it was a difficult time.
There was no question that it wasn't a perfect organization with a stellar medical scientific record that was coming in with no stains.
You know, there were some problems, image problems perhaps. So, we were concerned that that would be make it very difficult for people to be, you know, to warmly receive the institute.
So, the money really improved the probability because when you can bring money, while suddenly university administrators can see much more potential if you're bringing some money with you.
I think we'll ask for over the next time. Thanks, Dean.